College wrestler Wrestled a Bear off of
his teammate after he was attacked in
Yellowstone National Park back in
October Brady Lowry Kendall Cummings and
two other teammates were searching for
shedded Antlers when they surprised a
grizzly bear the bear attacked Lowry and
shook him around he said he didn't know
what to do so he just curled up in a
ball and took more thrashings from the
bear until Cummings got involved who
kicked hit pulled and wrestled to try to
get this bear off of his friend who at
that point suffered a broken arm and
puncture wound the bear then went after
coming severely injuring him before the
bear lost interest and left during this
time Lowry was able to get to an area of
cell service at dial 9-1-1 two other
teammates helped carry a very badly
injured Kendall Cummings off the
mountain Brady Lowry was able to walk by
herself Cummings underwent surgery and
the two are now okay